It was a cultural. You were
a and iron worker during the time of the
building of the harbour bridge. And they
get a. You know as
a seaman you know. Or rather their change
in air and i'm sure i don't know where
young shit. Where were you
born in pain and and when you
know you know three. You
were a seaman i was also
a seaman. Yeah yeah yeah
yeah no tree and i left the
states to come here. They give
a scorched in the very thing
ship and yeah i arrived here
in america
a ship. And when did you arrive here.
I remember nineteen twenty four
. You know exactly four and you did you
know you left the ship to do you jump or.
You know i left paid off for. You know
their way they stick stuff when i got my
first job or most regular way they did
actually the commission that was and going
under the leadership of john warner
monash victoriana aviation job.
In you know that time as you know
three times remain employed and
a job and there are other area of
commotion planned going pop converting
that brown coal in coal into
boilers that they were
building there then. And as
a person you saw the brown
coal in soria they saw and.
That was
a very good paying job because
there was general siam. And then
ago when i finished. What was your
job. My job was very getting back to
sort of the reggae and splicing
wiring so to see that you were
wrecked ing me with a past asian
extended past station and
a maverick asian plank for
a whole there and roll call
briquettes get planned
exactly where was that was that it wont
take you where was it more yellow and you
know it all more well he's
in starting. That hard work.
I swear it was all all mushy say it was
a bridge the bridge was hard
work tailed because it was in
a difficult. You know job
actually uncoupled on the
bridge itself in you into kindly
way nasty. It's raw eggs and
in the shops. I mean it seems point
so i started out in the brig
and then they started acting you started
a staggering extinguisher.
And we started back in the
shops and the other side assembly shop got
virtually nineteen cling
to twenty five and require
whatever units any 6:00
and exactly. But for
money. The chief of the iaea that i
haven't heard very much mention of
you know late all. Blah blah
blah they range. There's
a chap by the name on hip. Here below the
doorman general dolman wrongs and he
should have been given your credit for
the erection of the bridge and you know.
Talk about yet again it's
a need to raise other personalities
bradfield ok so greg
does to brag they will personally add
a sort of one is. In
charge of inspection and
bridge was designed by one long's he
designed was done in accordance in
cooperation with bradfield. Who
whole thing was going on loan and
keepers and like there was. Important for
a camera made as worrying and
as a job. As
a job. It was. I mean you had what
he was from the erection stage of
the of the shops. We had
talked radio for money. Verily
and all jack harris. Frank corrects
what we call him jack for some reason
. So there was
a welshman. Some people called him taffy.
Yeah yeah yeah that's right natalie.
He was
a i think he was welch. Yeah i think
again. Rob hardeep you know but they
brought him out from england doormen longer
didn't and don't i couldn't say i'm not
sure why did i ever wrote him
a real was here. He stayed here. He went
to new guinea. He stayed in australia. I
didn't go with the crowd was my longest
road. So i think he went to new guinea and
had several years there.
What it below la. Yeah
a funny thing. I am i
was working in 1940 as
a former boilermaker
join unions later on she
take and sean joined it before
the jury before he wore actually
i got
a good one and i think union and. Hand for
mine had
a message in nineteen
nineteen for the five who
requires
a six and me chimera finery. They
report on a couple. I want
a case assistance. Jack harries.
He said there's like in the universe
as the year every year. Drug
sack me. There's
a reaction on the wilson body shops and it
could shack anybody had any spot. Do you
needed. Where did. Where did he go.
Afterwards i mean did you hear what happened.
Term did he go back to a
military state here as
a leader. Then when we
finished yeah yeah. Carry jack
harris harris was there with us. This
is back in court this what happened
after after that you know and i don't know
what happened to him that he was what
was he before when rigor on the
on the north side was. Where
he where he was he was raised some reaction
is shocked that it was formed to go on
. You know. Yeah. Jimmy steen
i watch we all know him
here in china your honor on
this point i had an actual
creed very damn prevents on that
bridge. I left toward sara stray
lia but oh yeah there on
the bridge. I think i was
a poor for
a year working part years
away. I said. Then yeah. And
by brian shear way between
say juno and hand
you know for going condensing you
know lincoln and water supply
pipeline from port lincoln and.
It was called tev an hour then you
know and then i think that job
in about nine months came
back here. Got a job on
a bridge and own mind in that too.
When you when you first went on you were
working on the workshops in the first
instance and then did you. And then afterwards
the decoy on the erection afterwards
have been on there actually
on missions points on this
side and. The melton's point.
What did you do during the process.
Very stig's reggae
scaffolding pressure. Cranes
and i say i am really cranes and this
was the more money. There was always
cranes where young was jimmy steen.
A big scotchman scope with
a very difficult to erect
those no no no no i was in
a difficult. I first it became
a bit different. Yeah excel is
a big range said in travelling
over the bridge there where
they have
a director that they are on the wrong
side and there are smaller cranes
they have some big cranes to
be erected on the. Shoreside
attack rent. Yeah yeah but the direct the
creeper crane to be what if you were
wrecked the creeper crane to. Creep the
grange we are erected to where liberator
on the day came in first of
all the cranes on the very
very very links where the. Two basch
you know they're not really basis.
You know really basic stars. Call them
the kind of apartment towers. That
tower stay yet they're there
a button and they don't hold
a bridge and bridge race and.
On the bearings in this q-bot
and then something you know to
stretch you know all the wires
cameron's going to do a
whole. They range have
a there and then we had
tenants dug under the rock
and right around of course
there'll be a link to half
a mile to get the coming and going. Of the
. Sick. Going through the day again. Port
said i mean you were you ran them drowned
through the through the tunnels to do
this you shake. Ok then as when they're
around. Actually the canvassing
closest. Large scale
a rock and then cross it and questioning
kevin's where not directly on the
rock was the he had thick plates and
riding camels from whom we wear and tear.
To collecting in from cutting into the
rock and so how did you go about
threading it through. Did you start with
a small telegraph rope
so to speak. Yes yes i
thin k that's thin thin
thin no wires ropes. No.
Golden. Am true love.
Through the tunnel turning
over
a satellite and when that was over when
i met you you were right. You must have
erected the creeper crane before then. Yes
because the crane about the first and the
next. Do you remember what it was hard to
erect the jib of the creeper crane where
you would we working on that. Our current
crane you know she goes to auburn
when either side yet i was
talking to harry tom rob he's dead now
but he worked on the other side and he
reckoned as
a he was on he started is. His career at
sea under sail and he said the hardest
thing i ever had to do was to erect in his
life was directly the tip of the creeper
grain camera and when exactly
it grieved that crane estada
right from turnley was
a horrid. I told arch top top there
and that was
a wreck that on top of things. It was
very much harder than any abertay job.
Could have been and it could have been
jangling down. The way for four to
poorer for nine months then you know
all the air inside straight here.
And when i come back. There was
a lot already done and the hardest
work. I found was. Most unpleasant
was right and on top of the
ij. And they are acting out of danger
gosh mean and so forth in which we
never goes away. It is very strange
there when i came back was very
chilly and
a blue like hell and. Strong on top there
but there was nothing to hang
on to. Yes. No. Well we had
a proper action plan for erecting
fafsa form side. He even poor
people very very tense. Had to be
platforms and for there we won't flee
in the steel erection gang or where you
were just directing scaffolding and such
like i was only acting scaffolding now and
again my street time image here action.
So jack harris was the one who who was
he was acting as dogman in the steel
erecting going to you know remember how
many there were in the foreman. But he was
also acting as dogman and in the erection
of the steel wasn't who he was and yet i
was only in order to say yeah yeah. You
were on the south side where they showed
side. Well you might remember harry
tom robin who harry tom rob.
Felix faulkner ben tucker. And
drilling and they were in there and they
were in the erection going on the south
side tomlinson stare
jacks when no sanction
national action last guy
george harrison was
writing
a shot at the major mind when strange
things was we'd class langston
swims. Do you remember who was the
crane driver the creeper crane driver.
Now i don't. Quite
a few crane drivers and the job. Of the
carpenter shop on nelson's poor and the
south side. When they say yeah yeah.
And then they said they shop. I
don't shop for that and who's who and
who did you know jackeroo in those days
i tell you i don't have renters who saw him
here in time so i let him lots of time
since then usually because i was with the
public works the pipes and he was with
these contractors working for us. You
didn't know him but he his father was the
caretaker and he lived in doorman long's
office. I knew that i i know i don't. He
always living there somewhere near there.
He was and. On the other side. Yeah.
So when you when you went away before you
went away. You were on the militants
point side and when you came back to the
job you were on the south side and he's
outside. I started only on the side in
a direction to the shops. I started again
on the side when you started again on the
south side can you remember where the
bridge was to how far up it was
by that and i started earning
a show. It showed. It was surreal. There
you know you know you know i just used
ideas that you being we
self insure for the you
know steel erecting
a you know doing the preparatory work and
this is what we have our 1926.
Seven when you came back. Where
were they have our back then. That's
when i come back. And you know they.
When you come back they hadn't got very
far either. And he stayed there all the
rest of the time till 1930 one
or two did too. I think to
begin beginning to end the
bridge was opened. You know that there's
a you know anti-state and he's just
a special five shilling you
know major al qaeda there
who was your your foreman on the south
side of jackaroos on the north side it was
your foreman i'm not on the south side in
steam and that wasn't the steeler acting
going on the sound side was it.
Experience do you actually make
range about why we started erecting these
steel. You know to end on and progress
on their own. I was just that i was told
that ben tucker was the was the one who
was doing the dogman work on on the
sound side they could have been
. You bring back memories to me. I
completely lost their sense of who
they want you to be
a few people very well no. Felix
faulkner do you know i don't think
alex faulkner he was killed
or faulkner pork now
you know it's
a lie. Was he doing it. Well he was one of
the steeler actors and he was killed on
the deck level when he
was acting as dogman and
a piece of steel crane keep light
fell down and cut his leg off. Yeah i
read and i read there
. I remember very actually an
accident. And somebody having
a chap i think it's like got
a condom and who it was. I can't even
remember any names or guys who fell
off the bridge. Remember big kelly.
It was one it fell off and survived
that. Yeah that's one. Yeah. And
then yeah they go in there. Yeah
it was later
a foreman. Yeah i remember frank
doyle. Right. When he was
a diver two years he dived off the crane
once. Frank doyle here fred. Doyle
and and far only charlie days
here even charlie and
remember him getting five
plaid now you know and
you know. As
a sack getting sack. You know you know and
you know very good. Made him
a hero. Who's here. He'll
do you come across any holders up
like george scott or bob ross.
Yeah i came across a lot but
there i just don't have them but
a name which remember clarett
well i wrote him well here
and they him they're here around the
globe. I like camaraderie and he
he was
a cheap. If he was in charge
of erection wasn't he. He
was in charge of in all directions. The
whole bridge. Remember muir who james muir
re-airs yeah. And yeah. What was
his job as far as you could say
they were married and he was
any way that i'm you know
any engineer too. He was in charge of
the substructure at all the stonework
on the concrete and the pylons
to dubai had nothing to do
with you. Storm like this
stone storms gave me coursed and.
I don't know what you're involved
in an accident or so. Were you
involved in any accidents yourself.
You know. You know i you know
two and a lot of blood packs
a very important rule there
on the bridge. Probably
a chilly weather so called not as
cold as finland that's for sure.
You know and then you know
he's calling out what they
expect. And it could be
a very very call. And i pray you.
Don't get
a very very great deal
of information obviously
a long time and i had checked the multitude
of jobs since then. Where did you go
after that there are said
that i wonder why larry
is. Why don't they. Again shops and
so on the waterfront. I went i
also attended the tech for several years
and taxing the college and then go warily
in course over wages course and
so forth. And finally last job.
The last job i had before i joined the
department of public works was to
dockyard me and. I had left the reach of
an older and for henry and you
know change obviously you know day
and event for the very high by
numerous then then i decided
to give it up i had already my certificates
and i applied to the public works
department for any inspectors job and
good. And you stayed with them and
then i stayed what twenty years
on various contract jobs
. By applying. And broke and broken
hill and even closer and
very down which was
a very brain when over want
to cross the mountains to
do what you know the place to
work for you get to go to and
that's when it comes out and i can't think
what lawson somewhere. I know you know
just close to cut to just before
you come to them when it was
false and when laura.
Sure you are
a little yeah yeah that's right.
That's next. Occurred to me and
that time i was living in the mega long
wiley you know public works. House and
. At that stage. I've been in
a motel they do that in public works where
a country job was more
like jobs being some big
a job and to go much more water
supply. You weren't
married. You know and i
mean you know why. Teddy sixteen.
They work when with you everywhere.
My wife stayed here. He used the
engine helio flatly and see me here
and i finish reading public works
on the water supply and hands
factor.
That once in a really
bad night that you're
a very very very good can see and you
asked. And then came the mcclain
a morning supply to them was the work
comparatively easy at that just expecting
a real change. You know. All
the time and charge of the
contract workers contract.
Contract terms. That's where i met
jack ruby again he was working with
a contract. He had
a welding consultancy of his own
that. My right and i mean are you
talking about. Before his retirement i
suppose that would be about i mean here
is tired. Probably why you're
a lot older than him here picking here.
And how do you know. These clients
. I've just been talking to
somebody was ninety nine.